I'm gonna clear get home if you guys see
anything ninja related tell me cuz I am
back on my ninja kick okay I'm gonna get
shower radio so I can literally rock out
with my out or we could just stick
to the camping list get the supplies we
need right definitely
but first I want to get the stuff that I
want to get first all right just you
know travel shampoos look for him come
on 35 bucks for what
no it plugs into the car that's cool
good on camping there Paul Bunyan oh no
me my buddies are going to follow a
concert tour so we're just gonna like be
camping out it sounds fun yeah it should
be I'm not really a great outdoors guy
though you know unless there's a
bald-headed bear from the movie um
that's the great outdoors what you doing
[Music]
thank you who are you don't need some
help there my friend what um no no I'm
uh I'm all right
I'm just getting some pants how about a
larger size no III think they're good
hmm so where I'm out good day
you